have you seen the [ __ ] videos on tick
tock of those kids that like
manifest going to harry potter world or
not like [ __ ]
hogwarts have you seen that no oh yeah
yeah yeah
you've seen that right and then like uh
the people who swear
say they like have like a enter a dream
or like some
yes yeah can we find can we find one of
those
luke that's just called being high but
they're not though no they're not sober
they're stone sober and they definitely
like it's basically like you do some
process before you go to sleep
and like you tap on your notebook 17
times and then write some phrase and
then drink half a glass of water
and then jerk off or something like that
and you go to and then you go to
hogwarts in your sleep
this is literally like this isn't a joke
like there are like
i can't say i'm on witch talk yet so do
you have like a hashtag that can get me
there
um i can pull something up hogwarts
i don't know all right if you just if
you just uh
in regular google not cancel google if
you just search
uh going to hogwarts tick tock i bet you
you'll find some [ __ ]
yeah just search that on google it's
it's crazy it's like a whole sub
community on tick tock that
actually believes that you can do this
which i mean
who knows shifting yeah yeah yeah they
could be having
the best time like we're here making fun
of them and they're
like hanging out with hermione and ron
yeah yeah that sounds really cool it
sounds awesome yeah it sounds so cool
got some spells flying around playing
quidditch
i don't feel like i think it'd be funny
if you do this
this shifting the hogwarts thing you
just get there and you just get bullied
the whole time
[Laughter]
oh my god i did it [ __ ] ugh human
you're you're the only muggle you're the
only one without powers there believe
[ __ ] did you even get here get out
you're so annoying i can't believe you
guys figured this [ __ ] out
ugh something about you just uglier
all right let's let's do this stupid
tick tock kid
oh we got a dumb tick-tock kid everyone
it's bryce hall
r.i.p
[Music]
or you want a box or something fly away
from you
[Laughter]
oh you want to fight a spell now you're
throwing up slugs for the next 20 hours
so exactly get the [ __ ] out of my face
what's happening you like stranger
things right
all right let's hear this shifting
hogwarts thing i know this is old but
who gives a [ __ ]
[Music]
changed my life and i usually hate
guided meditations
but oh my god if you're yo paul's right
there don't even go
i usually hate guided meditation are you
like 16 don't you hate everything
who gives a [ __ ] what do you hate i
hadn't even heard the word
or the phrase guided meditation when i
was 16. yeah i mean
i can't say that but you you did know
about it
i didn't know like i've heard the phrase
i i never looked into what it was yeah
that's just because i was meditating
yeah yeah okay but it's fair yeah most
most
teenagers would probably hear guided
meditation and be like
is that like an audiobook for whacking
it or something
all right go ahead use this meditation
here
this is the title share this around hey
guys i'm just here to let you know that
the law of assumption works without fail
perfectly every [ __ ] time
if you don't know what it is i will link
the documents that i learned everything
from
you really just have to read it but i
just thought i would tell a little story
about how it worked for me today
and just a reminder this can be applied
to shifting you can get to your desired
reality through law of assumption
so this morning my dad was so [ __ ]
mad he was so angry he was screaming
to the point where i was just like i
can't [ __ ] be here i have to leave so
i got in my car and i drove an
hour out into the woods and i played
around in the forest for about an hour
and the whole time i was there i was
just making fake scenarios in my head of
like
us arguing and the you know the stuff i
would say if we were in an argument
but i was like why am i doing that i'm
the [ __ ] creator i create my reality
with my thoughts so i was like okay when
i get home dad's gonna be extremely
happy
extremely peaceful very much no yelling
very happy with me
i get home we peacefully and calmly
talked out our feelings for two hours
and then he suggested that we watch
harry potter together a movie that he
absolutely is hated on me for liking and
enjoying
hey all i'm going to be okay that wasn't
even that wasn't even shifting that was
like
that's just called getting an argument
yeah i kind of it was what went on to
the
forest and teach you all about in a
bunny costume shifting wearing a bunny
thing
i'm gonna teach you all about shifting
the blame yeah right
we got an argument and my dad thinks
it's my fault so i'm going to leave for
two hours and make it seem like it's his
fault yeah
another tournament
yeah i don't know yeah going to driving
an hour and to go in the
forest with a bunny what was that was
that a bunny here that she was wearing
on her yeah
yo playing hopping around in the forest
playing in the forest what how do you
play in
that's what i'm saying i don't know what
do you do in there i don't know i
the forest is not like a disney movie
where there's like paved
walkways worse generally i can totally
vouch for playing in the forest what do
you do in the forest
you just hang out with your friends you
build forts you you just play
maybe when i was like eight i'd go to
the forest and build a fort
if i get an argument at 16 i'm not going
to play in the forest
by myself i'm definitely not
yeah that's odd okay let's get some
shifting ones are there any
no is that she have a dildo what is that
man
i think that's a bat i'll have to skim
through and see if we can find that oh
she's coming to cancel us
shifting demonstration outside so y'all
can kind of so a lot of y'all are like
really focused on like
the journey part of your shifting
instead of the actual result which is
like you being in your desired reality
and instead y'all are like focusing on
like methods that you're using and stuff
so i'll get to the point i am holding a
baseball bat
and basically y'all are like focusing on
like looking at like the process
the process is down here and like you
can't like bounce can't balance the
baseball bat when you're focusing like
on the bottom part
when i'm focusing on the top half of the
baseball bat which is me being in my
desired reality
and i'm able to keep it still
[Music]
so yeah basically moral of the story is
focus on the results
can we get someone who's 18
talking about how to do this like at
least someone who can buy a cigarette
yeah we're skimming
i'm sorry i'm just we'll find it i'm
being i'm being facetious and i'm just
if i see another if i see another 16
year old with dyed black hair telling me
about how to shift reality
almost scream do your homework
see i thought this whole thing was like
they were what does it mean like does
that mean like when you're loose like
when you're
conscious then you're shifting to your
these are people that like aren't in
their desired reality that don't have
the best
situations and want to get somewhere
else yeah or is this
just lucid dreaming that's what i
thought it was yeah i just can't tell if
this is like some modern coping
mechanism for like
like abusive parents or yeah that's what
that's what it kind of seems like
yeah why are all these like so i got in
a really horrible argument with my dad
so it's like i want to shift my reality
yeah yeah all right i'll take back what
i said
shift away i in my room trying to shift
to my doctor
desired reality oh my doctor
damn i'm sorry i'm not 15. i don't know
what [ __ ] i didn't know dr
they changed the [ __ ] meaning of that
oh i'm crying i'm 16
so i i know this i'm definitely born in
2011.
i have shifted 21 i've shifted yeah so
anyways
these they go to they all go to hogwarts
it turns out if you just
turns out all these people's dr's or
hogwarts yeah
yeah if you can shift reality hogwarts
is probably the whackest place you could
go
yeah i'm gonna go to a [ __ ] old
castle yeah
everyone's just with sticks and frogs
where would you go where's your dr
my dear the dominican republic man
i would shift to the real dr
and go straight to a beach
[Laughter]
listening to music drinking something
cold under the hot sun
that's where the [ __ ] i'd go idiots are
going to hogwarts
you can go to a beach stupid you go to
tropical climate
you want to go put on [ __ ] yeezy
outfits and
shoot fire with sticks boo
yeah i don't know i know there's one
person always that fails one person who
can shift
listens to the patron it's like um
actually guys yeah if
hey if you do if you know about it let
us know what shift things yeah
yeah let us know how to shift it sounds
like a sick dance move
yeah yeah yeah what's up guys today i'm
going to show you a little bit of
shifting
i'm doing a shifting tutorial guys just
how you shift into hogwarts
[Music]
harry do you hear me hurry
harry what is good i'm channeling you
[Music]
we should have them shift onto the ship
oh [ __ ] no
if you can shift shift onto the ship
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like that i like scary as hell in the
middle of an episode
someone just appears here um
i shifted up here we're like get the
[ __ ] out of you out
security tackle but
giant alien security guard
[ __ ] shifters dude make a note wait
real quick
we have to do that next episode yeah we
have to like
cast a [ __ ] 16 year old girl
in the middle of next week's episode and
just show up for a second
[Laughter]
i'm shifting
we could also have structures i'm such a
big fan and she shifts back
to earth
[Laughter]
speaking of shifting now dude i really
got to take a shift right oh yeah yeah a
big watery shift oh yeah
it's it's about to pour out of my ass so
i'm gonna
put a b-line to that oh i'm shifting
[ __ ]
i'm taking a shift honey yeah go ahead
[Music]
how was your it was a good shift
i needed that something has really
messed up with my stomach